i'm fixing a consistency issue based on
the fact that
i just had to drastically restructure my
entire talk
okay um
okay so i just uh i know i know this
feeling you know i was fixing my slides
until the last minute so you know i was
actually on it until i found that
i couldn't talk about ggm's okay um
so if i share my screen then do i become
visible
uh yes yeah you are already visible to
everybody
oh hi everybody uh yeah basically like
on the on the screen you only see the
the panelists right but uh basically
speakers but uh
uh yeah you are visible to all
participants right now
okay cool let me just uh share my screen
[Music]
people hear it uh so this is good
uh except that uh okay so you're
unshared now right
uh am i not scared uh you are not [ __ ]
right now you appeared for a second and
then disappeared
oh i tried running it with my powerpoint
running
let's try this again now
yeah yeah
all right so uh yes without further ado
john will talk about computational
complexity of statistical estimation
so hi everybody i'm john kellner i am
one of the
along with prasad one of the people who
is in charge of this area
of computational complexity of
statistical estimation
estimation and so
we are very lucky to have a nice large
and exciting team from both schools
which i've put here
and we have a pretty good distribution
between both berkeley and mit
some people are even distributed by
themselves uh shaffy has managed to make
it into both
and um today what i want to do is just
run through kind of the basic
goals of the theme and then do some
technical stuff um i should give a quick
uh
uh pre-apology which was that i
learned about 30 minutes ago that encore
was speaking about ggm's as well as me
so i have drastically restructured my
talk in the last half hour
and we are going to just hope for the
best um so
i've changed my talk to be a little bit
more sums of squares oriented
and um yeah okay so
let me first just say what the high
level objective is of our
area and then i'll kind of talk a little
bit more about generalities and then
i'll start talking a bit about some
specifics
okay so the overall high level objective
of
this area is to understand the
computational and statistical trade-offs
involved in statistical estimation and
so this was our kind of
go-to blurb but i want to change it a
bit and just phrase it as
what should complexity theory look like
for data science and statistics
so um and i'm going to give a little
warning here which was
i'm about to caricature both statistics
and computational complexity
and i figure as long as i as a tcs
person caricature computational
complexity as aggressively as statistics
then it's probably okay
um okay so the short short version of a
motivation for this theme of our
um of c is just that classical
statistics
largely focus on sample complexity and
not computation
um if you and i guess i will make myself
safe in this statement by if there's
anything that does involve computation
just officially declaring it not
classical
but uh broadly speaking you know the
main results are what you could do from
an information theoretic standpoint
what can you hope to do if you have
infinite computation time
and lately what's been becoming
increasingly clear is that there's a
really substantial trade-off involved
and that if you look at what you can do
with finite computational resources
that definitely is not always the same
as what you can do with infinite
computational resources if you just look
at the information theoretic complexity
and more broadly there's been kind of an
emerging structure
of trade-offs between the quantity
quality
and just of the data that you have and
the computational resources you're
willing to devote
and how these relate to what statistical
problems you can solve and how well you
can solve them
and so i would put the
goal of this research theme is saying
that it will be to develop frameworks
algorithms and intractability results to
explore
this sort of new class of trade-offs and
i think you know in an ideal world what
we would end up with
is something that looks like what
complexity theory looks like now namely
something where we have an ability
to really precisely ask the question
of what is hard or easy ask find the
right ways to get the primitives to
which one can reduce
in order to get decent computational
hardness results and then get algorithms
that come as
close as possible to matching them
okay so uh my first general
generality before i get to some content
on this was that classical computational
complexity is really
not very well suited to data science
questions
and this was my hopefully aggressive
enough criticism of complexity theory
that people will forgive me for saying
that statisticians don't know about
computers
um and so why this is reasonable is that
you know reductions to np-hard problems
i guess are the bread and butter of a
first course in complexity
and anything in that vicinity tends to
it's they're very hard to come by when
looking at data science applications
and in particular the reason is that
usually the
uh questions that you want
don't really care about real instances
but you care about instances
that correspond to reasonable
probability distributions
and typically when you go through a
reduction process you end up with some
very
contrived or complicated distribution
and it tends to be very hard to get
these to be well adapted
to problems where you actually want to
solve from
reasonable distributions or say
something reasonable about problems you
actually encounter and there's actually
even kind of a stronger statement which
is that there are complexity theoretic
results that say that you can't use
complexity theory
um in that there are a bunch of results
that say that
under certain computational true
assumptions
uh you should not be able to get np
hardness reductions for a lot of the
sort of interesting classical problems
that you'd want to solve in a
um in a statistical estimation kind of
context
and so what i want to talk a little bit
about are just some possible other
directions
and then i'll um rather than trying to
survey all of them i'll just give some
background on one of them
uh the one that remains after encore's
talk and then
um kind of conclude by saying a few
words about the general directions one
can go
and so you know the question is what can
we do if we're not going to say things
are np hard
but we want to say things are hard and
one answer is just reduced to something
else
and that actually has been surprisingly
profitable um i'll say
more about that shortly uh the other
answer is that you could imagine looking
for
unconditional lower bounds and weaker
models of computation
and i'll also say a little bit more
about that so you know the first one is
you're gonna instead of looking for np
hardness you look for another you'll try
to find a new notion of hardness
um the second one is try to get lower
bounds in some model that is
not you know that is not all charring
machines
um and then the other things that we'll
focus on in this theme that i'm not
going to talk much about today
um are going to be insights from
statistical physics and
lower end upper bounds against specific
classes of algorithms
and so there's been a lot of great work
that's been done by a lot of people on
that previous slide in this direction
but just for time constraints i'm going
to
shy away from it okay and then of course
there's the very popular machine
learning approach these days which is
that you'll just assert that neural
networks solve all of your problems for
all parameter regimes and thus the
complexity is not a problem
um that one i'll also not talk about
much today but hopefully nobody else
will
either okay so um
[Music]
the broad goal in this research team is
going to be look for algorithms and
lower bounds and one of the things
that's come out is a very popular way to
do this and it's something that's been
very useful both from from some things
i've worked on but also things that
other people who are on
this group of uh this research theme
have worked on
has been the planting cleat problem and
so i just wanted to so we have a little
bit of context talk a little bit about
it because it actually has been playing
a substantial role
in the complexity theory to come you
know in fact one very
something that's been developed quite a
bit by philippe and uh and guy so
philippe regular and guy bressler among
others
has been the possibility of it giving us
one of the basic reductions that we can
use that we can develop planted clique
as a stan
planted clique hardness as a stand in
for np completeness
okay so let me briefly just uh tell you
what the planting clique problem is i'm
not sure
how many of you have seen it before so
i'll just run through it a little
quickly but the question is the
following
so the idea here is
um and so why i'm doing this before i
tell you what it is is that
um it's to be two reasons one is that
it's going to
it is a very it is a problem that people
think we can't do well
and so it will illustrate and it turns
out this has emerged as a really good
example of something to reduce to
the other is i'll talk a little bit
about a result that i and a couple
co-authors including encore
um and have uh have come up with that
was the start of a bunch of work on
unconditional lower bounds
for um classes of algorithms that
potentially could be ones you could
actually analyze in a statistical
setting
okay so planting click so the setup is
as follows the idea is you're going to
start with a random graph
um and so by a random graph i mean an
erdos-renyi random graph
which i'll call which i read is g and a
half and if you haven't seen this before
it just means every edge is in the graph
with probability of half so you randomly
independently choose whether to include
every edge and now
if you look at such a graph the biggest
cliques in it it's a very classical
result the biggest click
clicks in it will be of size o of log n
um and that was one of the first uh
reasons why
things that first results in the theory
of heritage trendy graphs
um so you should think there's a
log-in-ish sized click in your graph and
nothing bigger
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to on top of it you're just
going to throw in
a click with a whole on some smaller set
of vertices
so you'll pick some number omega
that we'll talk about what it should be
in a little bit and
you just add that as a clip to your
graph so you take your original graph
and you union
it
uh and now and now you should think like
an interesting value for omega should be
bigger than the original
click the biggest clique in your graph
itself so think of the liga
omega as being you know at least a large
constant time at least a constant bigger
than two say
times log n and then the question is to
find the clique
so if the clique is bigger than you
would
with high probability expect to find in
a random graph
then so it's with very high probability
true that you won't find substantially
larger
than you know say two log n click in the
random graph
so if you found one it should have
something to do with your planting clink
um and so the goal here is to find it
and from an information standpoint this
problem is super easy
and in fact uh all you do is you just
try every subset
but the question here is what is the
first question kind of the very
one that started this process was uh
when can you actually do this what are
the omegas that actually make this a
solvable problem
and so let me briefly say the sort of
what was known about it
and then i'll talk a little bit about
um where we are on it now and what it's
useful for so
there is a very easy algorithm that is
quasi polynomial time
so if i gave you any omega greater than
c log n
for c bigger than two there's a nice
easy way to find a planted clique you
just
try every subset of size um
omega and that if you find a clique
that's much bigger than you should have
in your graph it has to have a
substantial
overlap with your clique and then you
just do a little bit of cleanup
so that's the easy answer and easy
answer is an end to the login
you can find any sufficiently large
clique
there's then a very easy polynomial time
algorithm for a much bigger value
of omega namely if omega
is root n times log n
times a constant there's actually a very
simple polynomial time algorithm to find
the planted clique and if you haven't
seen this before maybe think for three
seconds of how to do it before i tell
you the answer
okay so um so if
um if you planted a clique that was
substantially bigger
then you know that was c root log n
times
n so that would make the degree of a
vertex
bigger than you'd expect to find in a
random graph so a random vertex should
be
of degree well it should have neighbors
with half of the other vertices
plus something that's like root n times
a constant so
if if you get root n log n times a
sufficiently large constant bigger than
that
then you shouldn't see that unless the
vertex is in the clique
and so that is the easy algorithm and so
right now i've given you two easy
algorithms
and there's a giant gap between what's
polytime and what's not polytime
um and then there's one step more that
you can do which
uh is that you can get rid of the root
login
uh you can get rid of the root log n
using a spectral method
and so this is kind of the start of the
more modern algorithms for the problem
it turns out you actually have to do
something a bit smarter in order to go
from root n log n to root n
and there's a result by a lone
probability in pseudocode from 98
that says that there's actually a
polytime algorithm for finding cliques
of size c
root log root n or bigger so we've
shaved off that root log n and
there the algorithm is a spectral one so
you basically instead of looking for
high degree things you're going to look
for big eigenvectors
eigenvalues and corresponding
eigenvectors and go from there
okay so that is the planted clique
problem and
why i bring it up is for two reasons so
the first one is that it's actually
emerged
as a hardness assumption
and so uh this started with philippe and
birthday's work
on um pca and um
they actually managed to show that so
planted clique is a statistical problem
which makes it a plausible candidate for
reductions
so you know the problem with why you
shouldn't try to reduce the threesat
is that that's an absolute kind of
problem it's not a there's no randomness
in the description of the question
it's hard to imagine getting a natural
distribution to come to it
now the reason that planted clique has
emerged as a plausible hard problem
to be studied here is that it actually
is one that encodes a distributional
assumption in a natural way
and is still one that we don't know how
to do better than some
still one where we have a substantial
gap between what is information
theoretically and computationally
tractable
and so um people actually have tried a
bit to do better than the root n
and as of now uh there is no better
algorithm than root n
for the clique you can find in power
pattern of complexity theory when one
can't solve a problem or prove it's
impossible you just name it
and call it uh planted clay hardness and
so
what um and it's turned out that this
has been a really good building block
for a lot of computational hardness
results in this
in in uh set in these sorts of settings
and so philly oops come back uh so uh
philly things collaborators have shown
some of these and started this area
where they showed that
you actually could show that certain
conjectures computational statistical
gaps for the planted
um uh for pca actually come from the
planted cleat conjecture
so that is if you conju the base
conjecture here is going to be that this
problem is hard and
uh you can actually show this so that
this implies other problems to be hard
as well
and since then this has taken off so
there's been a whole bunch of reductions
to
show statistical and computational
trade-offs and
recently one of the theme directions has
been understanding whether this is the
right problem and how far you can get
with it recently there's been
huge amounts of progress made by guy
bressler and his collaborators
in terms of showing what how well this
does as a good basic assumption
okay so that was planted clique and
due to my slight curveball on my talk
topic i am now going to talk a little
bit about how not to solve the problem
and so um
the natural question you'll ask is is it
actually hard
and i've always thought that you know
computational complexity theorists were
such pessimists
and that you know root n just like
there's this giant log end to root n gap
and
coming into this as someone with an
algorithmic kind of bent i always felt
like the goal should be to do better
and so there was a very there's a very
natural candidate
for a class of algorithms that could
hopefully do better on solving planted
clique
and it's called the uh sums of squares
hierarchy or the lesser hierarchy and
what i'm going to do with the rest of
the talk is first i'll tell you the end
result of where we're going with this
and then i'll tell you what the
hierarchy actually is
and then i'll say a little bit about how
it ties in to
the general goals of our theme okay and
so
the question i want to ask is is it
actually hard and what i'll describe for
you on the next slides
is the is a way of creating a hierarchy
of successively slower but more powerful
algorithms
and so what we'll see in a second is
that you'll you'll have a parameter t
and if for every value t you'll get a
stronger algorithm with a running time
that grows like
n to the o of t and so if you could
solve this problem
for t equal to some number that was
sufficiently small that would say a
large constant you could then get a
polytime algorithm for the problem
and i'll say a little bit about why but
one thing that the reason that this is a
plausible conjecture is that the
spectral algorithm can very much be
interpreted
as the t equals two version of this
system
and so i kind of had hoped the answer
was that this was
impossible that this was possible that
you could actually with even t equals
four plausibly do better
um there was a sequence of papers that
showed well there was a
paper that can that conjectured to
produce an integrality gap
for the entire all all hierarchies up to
like a root login degree
and it turned out to have a subtle bug
that made it
not a true proof and what made me really
optimistic that we could solve planting
clique
was that actually um the algorithms
about described could
um that the algorithms that i actually
described will it
um they actually at least break the
integrality gap instance
for that was previously known and so
the somewhat disappointing result from
an algorithmic standpoint but um but
good building block from a complexity
one is that actually
the sums of squares hierarchy i'll
describe for you sec in a second
has an absolute unconditional lower
bound
on planted clique problems and so the
result is that
um that for anything less than n to the
one half
uh so n minus any constant or even n
minus c
root d over log n uh you just can't do
it
there's an integrality gap to the sums
of square hierarchy and in fact
for any sub-logarithmic degree of the
hierarchy
you just can't find any clique of size
substantially smaller than
log than root n
and so why i mention this is that now
between these two
this starts to give a hope of proving
both unconditional
both conditional lower bounds for
computational complexity problems and
unconditional ones
against this class of algorithms that
i'll motivate for you now
okay so let me tell you about the sums
of squares hierarchy and then
um okay so this is something that's been
turning out
both on a positive and negative side to
be to be a very powerful technique for
understanding
problems in statistical estimation it's
got
both the best the upper best algorithms
for a bunch of problems as well as just
being
a hardness result and it
grows from it was introduced in a couple
different forms
um and i'm going to introduce it in one
that's not the way that either any of
these forms introduced it
it's i guess uh closest to the way
lesser had but not really
and so let me describe the goal as
follows so the goal is that we want to
solve some optimization
problem in the problem of click planted
clique we're going to think our goal is
to find the hidden clique
so we'll phrase this as just find a
large clique in our graph
and the sums of squares hierarchy
uh what it does is it asks us to try to
find something that's going to pretend
to be the moments
of a random variable supported on
solutions
and so let me say a few words about why
that's reasonable so the idea here is
we're trying to find the biggest clique
in a graph that is not a convex problem
that is not a polynomially time-solvable
problem in general
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to try to frame this
in a convex way and the way we'll do
that is we'll say okay how do you ask a
convex problem well
if we want to ask for a convex set to
look for then we can't look for one
solution because it's possible there
could be more than one
and then there's no way you can as a
convex sort of setup know which one to
pick
and so instead what we're going to do is
we're going to look for a probability
distribution over
all solutions to our problem so
that at least is a convex thing so
looking over all probability
distributions but it's a grossly
unsolvable one it's harder than our
original problem
if i want to find or at least as hard
and so instead we're going to
our relaxation here is that we're just
going to instead of trying to find the
probability distribution
we're just going to try to find things
that look like they could be its moments
and so this is the way i want to frame
the sums of squares hierarchy this is
really the lesser hierarchy
and what it says is you're going to look
for an operator that inputs polynomials
of degree less than or equal to d
and spits out numbers um and those
numbers are going to presume to be
the expected values of the polynomials
that
are given as inputs and we'll call this
a pseudo expectation
and so what i'm going to do to define
the hierarchy is i'm just going to
define the rules that these pseudo
expectations should obey
and just in case you've seen things in
other settings and haven't seen this yet
note that classical semi-definite
program relaxations are going to
directly correspond to this
degree too okay so here are the
constraints that we're going to have
um and uh what are they so we want to
define
expected val like we want to try to find
something that looks like it could be
the expected value of polynomials
and what do we know about this so first
of all we know it's linear
we know that the expected value of one
is one and then there's the real
constraint that carries the strength of
the hierarchy this is kind of the main
one that actually really
is what gives you computational leverage
um if you're going to us
you want to show that for any polynomial
at all
note that if i were to square a
polynomial
over the reals i get a non-negative
number because for any value that i plug
in because
squares are non-negative and so all
we're going to do is we're going to
assert that the expected square
of any polynomial is greater than or
equal to 0.
and now if you think about that if what
we're going to try to do is make a big
list of moments of our random variables
so we'll look at the expected value of
every monomial
this now gives us a whole bunch of
constraints it says any
um you know any sum of these things that
actually corresponds to the square of a
degree less than or equal to d over 2
polynomial
has to have a non-negative expected
value
okay and so this is the general
hierarchy i now want to throw in
some more that will be tailored to the
planted clique problem and then
um and what will those be so in the
planted clique problem we're looking for
a zero one solution
and so we know that the x's the
variables that we're trying to find
well how should we actually encode our
problem in this form we should encode it
as saying let's try to make
a vector that's got a one in every
component on the clique and a zero
outside of it
uh and so for that we can then um
just that gives us the constraint that x
squared equals x for every one of our
variables and so we have
as the the assumption when encoding the
fact that our solution should be zero
one
will throw in this constraint it will
say that for any polynomial
if x squared equals x then x squared
times p should equal
x times p and note that x squared equals
x is precisely
a quadratic that encodes that your zero
one
okay so um the other constraint we're
gonna do is we're gonna look for a big
clique
so we'll require that we have an we're
trying to find
the moments of a probability
distribution over
a clique of size omega and so over
cliques of size omega so we'll encode
that the expected size of our clique is
omega
now if we're putting an indicator
function for the clique that just means
the expected sum of the x of is omega
and
and there that there are no we don't
take any xi and xj when there isn't an
edge
okay and so that is it that is the sums
of squares hierarchy
um and it turns out that you can
actually solve it
so it turns out that if you have um
you know that first of all this is a way
of encoding our clique problem if you
imagined removing the little tildes from
all of our e's and i were to just say
for you
find a probability distribution whose
expected values for the thought for
polynomials meet these constraints
this would exactly encode looking for a
probability distribution over clicks of
size omega
and so that would be great we would have
the answer
and so the tilde is just the relaxation
where we're only going to require
that we obey these constraints on um on
expected values of polynomials rather
than being an actual distribution
and it turns out that there is an end to
the ofd time for finding such operators
um called the uh degree d sums of
squares algorithm
um and uh so since i'm running a little
short on him let me say a couple more
words about how this fits into
everything
so now why is this relevant to
uh getting a getting data science's
complexity in place
okay so first of all this is a very
plausible algorithm for solving a lot of
problems i initially thought sums of
squares would solve planting clique
and it doesn't i was very upset by the
result um but it turns out that
there's that this actually those
techniques in it or
that we used to do this were actually
very well suited to proving hardness
results
for distributional problems problems
with sort of
distributional inputs some things like
planted clique where you're trying to
find some sort of structure in a sea of
randomness
um and the techniques in this work
actually have led to a bunch of
different directions for understanding
how to construct
uh relaxation lower bounds for these
relaxations for huge for a bunch of
these problems
um on the flip side it hopefully
provides some ground
grounding for understanding both
how we can get more unknown how we can
get other problems with unconditional
lower bounds
and uh i know maybe it also will tell us
a better way to solve the problem i'll
remain optimistic as an algorithmist
um okay so i think i am out of time uh
so
uh thanks everybody and if there's any
questions just let me know
cool thank you john thank you john
so let's see i think we have slightly
less than one minute for a question so
if if there is any question uh
uh please type them in the q a
and uh in the meantime uh bean are you
there
yes i'm here okay yeah in the meantime i
guess you can
uh start setting up your slides
do i have the right to share the screen
oh sorry i mean
now i think you know not not until next
time
sorry no problem
okay so i i don't see any questions so
thanks john again